okay let's try the five one six area
code caller from five one six you're on
tell me who you are where you're calling
from and what's on your mind hey David
how you doing I'm John from Springfield
New Jersey
what's on your mind John I my question
is a little involved so just give me a
second to make my case the curious on
what your thoughts are on presuming that
you've been following up with the latest
news with Harvey Weinstein scandal and
just Hollywood and the Twitter boycott
and so forth want your thoughts on the
work on the current climate and
reactions to the Harvey Weinstein
scandal and the very real a scary
paradigm of men in power using their
position of influence to harass and
molest and rape women without fear of
consequence but particularly with this
climate of the finger-pointing and
putting so much stock in accusations
rather than genuine convictions you know
sort of alluding to I'm not sure if
you're familiar with like the Woody
Allen quote that's been sort of
misinterpreted but still distasteful
regarding witch-hunt in Hollywood again
I'm not trying to allude that I have any
sort of sympathy for Harvey Weinstein or
anything but just based on this general
attitude of putting so much stock in
accusations it just reminds me very much
of the Red Scare in Hollywood in the
nineteen late 1940 yes so a couple
number one I would hesitate to go to
Woody Allen one way or the other on
anything related to sexual impropriety
the guy is with his adopted stepdaughter
right he's he's now with married I don't
know if they're married or he's
romantically involved with his adopted
stepdaughter so I wouldn't necessarily
go to Woody Allen first and foremost on
what what's going on with know how many
was losing to the fact that just because
he had you know I'm not trying to defend
his you know his personal history or
science put him as some sort of
authority figure but I I'm he pointed
out you know a very real
witch-hunt like mob mentality there i
would like to talk on well listen i mean
my thoughts on weinstein are similar to
with Bill Cosby right I mean this is the
guy who appears to be by every
indication a total scumbag and these
allegations they much like with Bill
Cosby they're coming from women who
don't know each other much like with our
current president Donald Trump women who
to argue that they are somehow
conspiring to concoct stories that date
over decades and decades etc I mean
there's no defense you're going to hear
from me of the alleged actions because
my default is not to not believe the
alleged victims
and if the question is that not there
ever was
accusations a sexual assault course
there are of course there are sometimes
false accusations of sexual assault but
I'm not I don't know specifically what
what it is you want me to comment on
just particularly this it's really sort
of an oppression Olympics extension I
think with regards to you know the me to
hashtag trending on Twitter like that
I'm you know it's it's just kind of
strange sort of daya fication of a
victimhood and and it's and just putting
you know there's like the Casey Affleck
thing I'm not too familiar with his
whole thing but just the fact that he's
being considered a sexual you know in
the fact that settlements are being used
as confessions of guilt and so forth and
if you listen settlements are not
confessions of guy settlements are not
confessions of guilt but if you see a
pattern no but how in general of course
not but in general how they're there
it's it's so often seen and suggested
that that it is it's it's just kind of
IDI are you at all concerned with just
general and I think it's fair to say
leftist culture in general of just not
rushing to the defense of the accused
but which is what happens in a liberal
democracy you know you know innocent
before proven guilty yeah listen I'm
concerned with it I'm concerned with it
insofar as I've identified you're mixing
a bunch of different issues right you're
talking about deification of victims now
we're talking about oppression hold on a
second you're talking about oppression
Olympics you're mixing a whole bunch of
different stuff
so we've got to really break these now
they're all it all it's it's it's it's
inseparably Antoine again I don't think
that unfortunately I listen if you see
it is all the same thing you see it as
all the same thing I don't know I'm
trying to give you a little wine I'm
trying to give you an answer to at least
part of your question and you're not not
letting me so maybe we'll talk about it
at some other time but these are
separate issues I've been critical of
some of the issues you've mentioned
you're also wrapping things together
that aren't actually related
operationally I don't think I'm gonna
have an answer that you'll be ok with
today so maybe we'll address it in the
future
and I was just curious what your
thoughts were well you didn't let me
then give them to you you kept telling
me I don't understand okay so maybe
weren't addressing my question
specifically you were you were defending
your own track saying I stand with the
women I don't you know I'm not asking
your position on the individual cases
against Harvey Weinstein I'm talking
about the culture yeah well I'm telling
you the call I'm against the idea of the
of oppression Olympics I think
oppression Olympics is different than
the default of not assuming accusers of
sexual assault something that's highly
stigmatized are lying like do you see
how those are two different things yeah
but I'm not I'm not implying that women
are lying I'm just talking about the
general culture I don't know you want me
to issue some blanket critique of the
general culture and what I'm telling you
is what you're calling the general
culture are different issues and if you
don't agree to that then we there's
really nothing to talk about
okay I was just just wondering if you
had made these similar sort of
observations that do you think I'm too
generalizing or two to make drawing I
don't know it seems that you you think I
haven't unfair sort of observation I'm
not saying you're being unfair I'm just
saying you've decided how these issues
are related and unless I answer with it
with that as an assumed part of it
you're not going to agree with me so I
think let's put a pause on it there okay
that's it four calls this week some good
ones some very short ones some longer
ones we didn't agree with the premises
with every call but what I can tell you
is that we will take calls again